-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're here.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, this is nice.
Earlier tonight,
the Bidens hosted
the president of South Korea
and his wife
for a state dinner
at the White House.
Yeah, Biden wanted to meet
with the most powerful people
in South Korea,
but BTS was busy, so...
[ Applause ]
But the state dinner was fun.
The South Korean president
was nodding off
because of the jet lag,
and Biden was nodding off
because it was 6:00 p.m.
and that's late, late.
I saw that the guests
were served Maryland crabcake,
fennel and cucumber slaw,
and a yellow squash soup.
Yeah.
Then, like every
other fancy meal,
everyone hit up
a McDonald's immediately after.
"Let me get a quarter pounder.
Starving."
Well, people are
talking about this.
Today, Disney filed
a lawsuit against
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
for waging a
"relentless campaign
to weaponize government power"
against the company. Yeah.
In an official statement,
the head of Disney's
legal team said...
[ Donald Duck voice ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow. Thank God.
Thank you very much, Donald.
-[ As Donald Duck ]
Go duck yourself.
-Oh.
[ Cymbal plays ]
-Duck. Duck.
-Go duck my--
-Go duck yourself.
-Yeah.
-DeSantis will be represented
by the Florida attorney general,
while Disney will be represented
by She-Hulk, attorney at law.
Disney hadn't hasn't taken
a politician to court
since they sued John Bolton
for copyright infringement.
[ Laughter ]
Geppetto.
Speaking of Florida governor,
apparently former President
Trump is listening to insiders
who are urging him to make
DeSantis his running mate.
[ Audience groans ]
I have a feeling
adding DeSantis to the ticket
will be like adding
Mentos to Diet Coke.
You know?
Meanwhile, I read that
Trump is threatening
to skip the Republican
presidential debates.
Trump was like,
[ As Trump ]
"As people keep telling me,
I have the right
to remain silent."
[ Laughter ]
"A lot of people
telling me that."
A Republican debate
without Trump?
Even C-SPAN2 was like, "Pass."
But right now,
Trump has a lot going on.
He's got a new book,
he's on the campaign trail,
and he's still
under investigation.
So to find out how Trump's
feeling about everything,
he actually agreed to join us
for an interview.
So let's ask him
a few questions right now.
Mr. Trump,
thanks for doing this.
-Jimmy Kimmel.
[ Laughter ]
-Close enough. Now, you --
You've got a new book out called
"Letters to Trump."
How much of your book
did you actually read?
-Like a page or two pages.
-Okay. Okay.
The book has a lot of letters
from famous people
like Oprah and King Charles.
What would you say
is your favorite letter?
-The letter C.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, your your reelection
campaign is in full swing.
What do you think Americans say
when they think about a rematch
between you and Biden?
-I want to vape.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Uh, okay.
Well, Biden is leading you among
women, independents and seniors.
Is there anywhere that you've
been leading Biden?
-Arrests.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, you've talked a lot
about all of your successes.
Can you give us
two examples of things
that you could have done better?
-Don Jr.
and Eric.
-Oh.
[ Applause ]
-Back to the election.
Do you think
that you can beat DeSantis?
-Oh, yeah, sure, sure.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you think
you can spell "DeSantis"?
-No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
[ Applause ]
-Finally, before you go,
can you do an impression
of someone
whose dentures are falling
out of their mouth?
-[ Slurred ]
God bless the United States.
-There you go. I appreciate it.
Thank you very much for
joining us, President Trump.
Thank you very much.
Nice of him.
Well, get this, guys.
Today, a congressman
from Oklahoma
brought Ronald McDonald
and Grimace to the Capitol.
Here's a photo.
Yeah, quite a fall from grace
for Tucker Carlson
and Don Lemon.
But hey, you know,
a gig is a gig.
A gig's a gig.
When Trump saw Ronald McDonald
was there,
he was like,
"I'm storming the Capitol.
Let's go!"
Well, guys, let's switch gears.
I love the springtime,
all the nature.
Let's just go around and say
what we love most about spring.
I'll start.
For me, I love the --
-[ Beautiful singing voice ]
♪ Rain, rain ♪
♪ I love the smell
of the rain, rain ♪
♪ Rain and my face
and I'm run, run ♪
♪ Running in place ♪
♪ And I'm loving
the smell of the ♪
♪ Sun, sun ♪
♪ I love the warmth of
the sun, sun ♪
♪ The sun on my nose
and the sun, sun ♪
♪ Shine on my clothes ♪
♪ And I'm loving
the warmth of the ♪
♪ Wind, wind ♪
♪ I love the rush
of the wind, wind ♪
♪ Wind in my hair
as I dance, dance ♪
♪ Dancing in air ♪
♪ And I'm loving
the rush of the ♪
♪ Rain on my face,
sun on my nose ♪
♪ Wind in my hair,
sun in my toes ♪
♪ Dance of the sea,
flying so free ♪
♪ I love the way of the rain ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Moving on.
Well, this is wild.
Ahead of his coronation,
a life-sized chocolate bust of
King Charles has been unveiled.
Take a look at this thing.
Yeah, yeah.
-Oh.
-They stopped at the shoulders
because they were like,
"I think this is creepy enough."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, guys, did you see this?
Beats is launching new
transparent earbuds.
Here's my advice.
If you drop one,
move on with your life.
Not gonna find it.
[ Applause ]
Move on.
And finally, there's
a new smart device
called Companion
that babysits your dog
by entertaining it, feeding it
and monitoring its health.
Yep. There's also
a cheaper option.
It's called not having a dog.
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody.
♪♪
Oh, good show!
What a show tonight!
What a show we have for tonight.
One of our favorites,
he is the co-anchor
of "Good Morning America"
and his skincare line,
Michael Strahan's
skin and shave routine
is available now.
Michael Strahan is here tonight!
One of the all-time best.
I'm very excited about
our second guest as well.
She is a best-selling author
whose books have sold
over 90 million copies.
Yeah.
The movie based on her novel,
"Are You There, God?
It's Me, Margaret"
is in theaters Friday.
Judy Blume
is joining us tonight.
-C'mon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And we got great music
from Black Thought
and El Michels Affair
featuring Kirby.
Gonna be good, bud. Thank you.
-Guys, right now, it is time
for "Tonight Show" hashtag.
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtag ♪
♪ Hashtag ♪
-Now, this week
I sent out the hashtag
#IfIWasPresident,
and I asked you guys
to tweet out something,
funny or weird things
that you would make happen
if you were elected president.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you all
for playing along.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#IfIWasPresident tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This one's from niko-seattle.
[ Applause ]
We can get behind that.
-Come on.
-This one's from Jenna2NYC.
This one's from mollys-mom.
-Yes, exactly right!
-This one's from rstare.
-That's fun.
This one's from,
speaking of mullets,
this was from LongHairedGuy31.
Disgrace!
How dare you!
-Fix it! Mm!
-How dare you, sir?
-[ Imitates whipcrack ]
[ Glove slapping sound effect ]
-I scream.
-I scream!
We all scream for ice cream!
[ Laughter ]
-It's iced cream.
-I scream, you scream.
We all scream for ice cream!
[ Cheering ]
[ Glove slap sound effect ]
Good day to you, sir.
This one is from geoffjeff.
-geoffjeff?
-geoffjeff55.
[ Cheers and applause ]
geoffjeff!
-What do you want
your username to be?
"Jeff."
-"Geoff Jeff."
-"Just Jeff?"
-No, Geoff Jeff says it, man.
He means it.
"Make it more legal."
-[ Laughs ]
-This one's from LaceyDawes.
Yeah.
-Come on!
-What are we supposed
to do with that thing?
-This one's from RUExcite?
[ Applause ]
-Sure. Sure, why not?
This one's from cvanrysdam.
[ Applause ]
-Sure.
-Classic.
-A classic. [ Laughing ]
-I've heard that joke, yeah.
-Well, how many hot dogs?
You got the eight hot dogs.
Right?
-Right. No, uh...
[ Cymbal playing softly ]
-And how many rolls you get?
-Six.
-What's the problem?
-10 and 9.
-I think it's 10 and 8, yeah.
Yeah, I think you get
10 hot dogs, 8 rolls.
-10 dogs?
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-So 10 hot dogs.
-10 hot dogs and 9 rolls.
-You got to get two naked dogs.
-Sure.
-Throw two dogs in one bun.
-Yeah. Whoa.
-Hey.
-That's right.
-It's a family show.
Two dogs, one bun. Yeah!
-You're being dirty.
I'm talking about hot dogs!
-geoffjeff55.
-Come on.
-[ As Donald Duck ]
Oh, goodness me!
-Oh, hey, Donald. Donald!
-This one's from johncooper23.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, I know that one.
That one there?
-Last one's from
LiterallyHatGuy.
There you have it.
Those are "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites, go to
TonightShow.com/hashtags.